comment on fait si on est par exemple
restaurateurs traiteurs
justement on a on à aziz ben taleb dans
le public et commerçons aziz qui est
président des traiteurs de france et
traiteur en ile de france
il a perdu 95 % de chiffre d'affaires à
6 vous pouvez vous lever admise merci
merci d'être avec nous ce soir mais
c'est à dire si aziz oui merci de cire
et de me donner la parole mais si vous
me permettez avant de répondre à ça oui
nous ça fait trois ans qu'on vit ça oui
c'est on est toujours au devant de toute
critique m'étais avancer avancer parce
que comme ça qu'on est nous qui sont les
premiers bien sûr les restaurateurs les
traiteurs alors les traiteurs bien sûr
jeunes femmes prenant des traiteurs
marcel parlera très bien ce qu'on
travaille ensemble ou syndicats marcel
bénézet élu à la chambre de commerce de
paris président théo sachant bien le
cafés bars et brasseries indépendant
vient des événements si le groupement
national des indépendants ont tous des
cons des fonds que des indépendants je
suis présent d'avenches
ce que je voulais dire ça fait trois ans
qu'on vise à caen il ya les attentats
c'est nous les premiers cas mon vécu sa
nature quand ils egrève 1
c'est nous les premiers qui vivent ça
besoin sur des idées gilet jaune on a
toujours vécu ça mais là où j'en ai en
pis on décembre et en janvier
rappelez-vous encore les grèves c'est la
retraite on a encore vécu ça ça fait
maintenant trois ans comment une pe
comme nous on peut surveiller les a ce
qui veut dire c'est pour ça qu'on
alerter on a rencontré bruno le maire on
a rencontré la ministre du travail et à
chaque fois
bien sûr il ya des mesures moi je vous
dirais sa démesure est en dessous
c'est alors et il me serait même
question c'est en fait à this is a pris
effectivement ce que tout ce que vous
avez dit monsieur nation au point que
toi ya dix ans éric ce qui est dit
aujourd'hui le 4 2 4 mars
nous les fait partie de l'association
des traiteurs de france
en trois jours on a perdu 4 millions
d'euros 4 millions 4 millions d'euros en
trois jours un conte qui veut dire et ça
a été mais franchement là on parler de
cul parler de tout cela nous parler
traitants mais je ne veux pas que tu es
sur 24 l'accord 24 qu'on a eu on a fait
un sondage 24 qu'ils ont répandu en
perdu alors aujourd'hui mois pour moi ce
qui veut dire dès que ça commence et les
demandes sans cesse des annulations
bayal son allié comme un salarié à 10 27
salariés et aujourd'hui vous faites
comment eh ben on va les payer
ah bah alors bien sûr la paix le
le champ de mars il y en a mais le
chômage partiel on a commencé à voir
avouer qu'on a pensé une seule chose que
je peux les féliciter ce gouvernement
une facilité les choses
c'est à dire ça avait plus rapide mais
pas contre moi j'ai une structure que
comptable j'ai des personnes mais dans
les petites pme
est-ce que 90% des traiteurs qui font
représente 15 mille entreprises en
france n'ont pas cette rupture
aujourd'hui sont complètement abandonné
personne
moi j'ai demandé à la ministre qui ne
répond toujours pas s'il est bon ton
aujourd'hui qu'à mettre une plateforme
avec un numéro qu'on peut les aider à
grandir with me liger travail d'accord
khaled kaïm héros comme on a fait pour
tous qui ont les aides qu'on les
accompagne
nous on au syndicat dont on est
submergés on sait même pas on n'a même
pas les réponses à des questions qui
mettent en quatre
un exemple je me rattrape et techniques
scud mois sert il
on sait pas aujourd'hui kobo comme le
salarié va être indemnisées parce que
nous sur notre branche on est sur 39
heures est-ce qu'ils vont aux salariés
ce qu'ils veulent a dit miser sur 35 30
69 36 à penser encore 35 36 c est le
mien au tout autour du phare celle
autour du spic exaltation entreprises
pas du salarié la charge des entreprises
alors moi je ferais maintenant
d'entreprise alors que nous au delà des
minispaces qu'on nous fait croire ça y
est c'est pas c'est pas la solution on
nous indemnise 7 euros 74 de leurs
imaginez vous comment vous teniez plus
les charges patronales qui font toute
une à payer ses débuts cette hausse en
quatorze le taux horaire est de combien
de gens qui ne valaient cadre chez moi
ils touchent important manteau horaire
du smic s'il vous plaît souple en
apprenant aux techniques aimerait pas
rentrer dans les clous voilà je vous ai
dû me témoigne âge à 10 la mesure
simplement ce cas va faire c'est secte
et semaine font tiendra pas plus on ait
pu trésorerie on a plus de frags
mouvement maintenant comment on pouvait
tenir vous à moi je dirais à moi à moi à
moi ça mais adnane hajji chaleureux avec
sursis
comment voulez moi le mois d'avril
j'épuise comment mois de mars et
finissent le mois de mars et puis
comment tu veux dire car il donne dans
le voyage juger une personne voilà
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai on appelait
on a enquêté la guerre durant les deux
dernières semaines
ils ont eu cinq ils ont eu beaucoup plus
d'annulations
bien sûr que de réservation c'est un
crabe c'est la première fois c'est
historique des voies la voie pour une
agence voyage samedi à ces histoires
dites quoi avant le 10 avant le discours
donc nous imaginent étudiants on va se
passer dans les prochains jours et avec
la bourse qui vont encore dévissé de son
sang ça va des 10 et demain christopher
je pense que la bourse sera pas du tout
va pas réagir à cela on a vu on a eu une
séance ce qui est catastrophique
le problème ce qui est emmanuel macron
nous présente le premier étage de la
fusée mais c'est pas suffisant vous le
dites vous même si vous n'avez pas de
chiffre d'affaires mais si on reporte la
fiscalité à quelques mois vous avez donc
le risque aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir
effectivement dans des secteurs qui sont
clés beaucoup beaucoup de faillites
le tourisme c'est le cas d'école le
tourisme vous avez 2,8 millions
d'emplois en france qui sont liées au
tourisme